Avengers end game officially confirmed
that Captain America is worthy of
wielding the mighty mystical mill near
but the film didn't explain why it took
so long for the star-spangled Avenger to
summon the hammer particularly when he
had the opportunity to do just that back
in Avengers age of Ultron thanks to new
Intel from the masterminds behind the
biggest film of all time we finally know
why cap didn't lift me only er until
endgame during an ask me anything
session on reddit the Russo brothers
fielded a question about Captain
America's ability to wield Mjolnir the
square-headed sledgehammer only able to
be utilized by those the Asgardian gods
believe is worthy whosoever be he worthy
shall haveth its most famous user is of
course the ass guardian god of thunder
floor audiences got the first hint that
captain america would be worthy of
wielding the weapon in age of Ultron
when Thor invited the rest of the
Avengers to try their hand at lifting
Neal near with Steve Rogers stepped up
to the plate he was able to ship the
hammer slightly unlike the rest of the
crew who couldn't even make it budge
this caused Thor to perk up in a seat
and look visibly concerned that Steve
would genuinely end up swinging me ol
near through the air an end game when
Captain America summons me earlier
during the intense final battle against
Thanos row Thor is totally pumped
[Music]
[Applause]
this suggested that the god of thunder
had known for years that cap was worthy
of wielding the hammer likely
recognizing that fact way back in age of
Ultron it subsequently caused many
including one curious Reddit user to
wonder whether Captain America could
always wield Mjolnir and was thus able
to lift in an age of Ultron and simply
decided not to or if he accrued
worthiness over time Anthony Russo
explained on reddit that in his
interpretation
Captain America always could pick up me
ol near and realize that during the
party at Starks place in age of Ultron
Anthony wrote our interpretation of the
famous scene at Ultron was that when he
realized he could pick up me ol near be
quickly chose not to because he didn't
want to embarrass Thor why might Thor be
embarrassed by his fellow Avenger
picking up and putting to use his famous
weapon you ask well it's probably down
to the fact that anyone deemed worthy
enough to wield Mjolnir instantly
obtains all the powers Thor has when
they lift it combine the abilities me
only er grants its users with Captain
America's super strength durability and
near indestructible vibranium shield and
it's easy to see why Thor might have
gone red in the face of cap lifted me ol
near an age of Ultron plus there's the
issue of Thor making a big deal about
being the so-called chosen one not an
earthly mortal like the rest of the
Avengers he's obviously pretty attached
to old me ol near Oh sometimes it takes
a second cap was sweet to save his meal
near wielding moment for endgame since
it had much more emotional heft and
caused Thor to be joyful instead of
embarrassed there was a huge payoff in
watching Captain America lay the
smackdown on Thanos using me only ur and
his super shield the moment was
certainly one of the most impactful of
the entire film with audiences around
the world cheering in their seats when
it happened
scene Steve Rogers lifts me all near an
age of Ultron could have been funny but
watching it happen in endgame was
infinitely more movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel then hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you